[Music]
in lawyer trouble news Oh submitted by
Mada Mada Mada Mada the Supreme Court
will now hear the case of a man whose
lawyer defied him during a murder trial
why him like I ain't gonna help you like
win against his will
when against his wishes so the client
says I plea not guilty and a lawyer goes
Wow oh the lawyer with the [ __ ]
conscience but it's also no or he was
trying to get a better bargain also not
his warranty hitman what she hit the
lawyer was trying to do a plea bargain
and the guy was like I don't I'm not
guilty I don't I'm not gonna say I'm
guilty and the lawyer was like he's
guilty to try to get the better deal did
you read the story cuz I know I just was
guessing because like I was trying to
seems like kind of common not common but
then that seems like the only reason
yeah yeah and it is actually kind of
common for lawyers like especially in in
a in a trial like this so this man his
name is Robert McCoy I know that did you
Mickey I didn't know that real good
you're on jellies you got one but she
still got one more on you cuz it's two
to one out okay all right we'll see no
money on Stevie's we catch up a lot of
time on the video look down there baby
I'll show you Bart I'll show you I got
your back Nicky we got Thank You jail
for come on let this took place in a
courtroom another one
back in May of 2008 in northern
Louisiana Roberts McCoy was accused of
killing his ex-wife's mother stepfather
and teenage son so he's being accused of
these Greenville the whole family
Robert claims that he was out of state
at that time in that these people died
from a police led drug ring that's what
he's claiming so Larry English is the
lawyer here he was hired by his McCoys
parent his last name is English kind of
cool that's really dumb yeah so English
here he thought that the case was
unwinnable and so due to a ton of
evidence against McCoy which I don't
know what the evidence was and so he
proposed a plan to plead guilty like
when Nikki was saying so then McCoy
would not be put on death row so English
is saying that he felt that as long as
he was his attorney he was his ethical
duty to do what he thought was best to
save his life even though he wanted to
he wanted him to get acquitted so wait a
minute so is there a police conspiracy
behind all of this because mr. McCoy is
stating that a police led drug ring is
what killed that family so it sounds
like to magic Shh everything ah the ball
guy he's the fall guy the lawyer so
what's going on I smell the Ricoh coming
definitely get these guys I'm ready
can we get it there's no Rico yet we get
Rico point taken away Oh Rico Oh we'll
get a Rico Rico the cops I'll fight joke
come on man
there you go thank you John
hey we gotta be the unbiased balancers
all right all right we'll see well so
join any side I'll never forget this oh
no I'm on the side of the law so then
English plan like every previously
mentioned it's not uncommon so they were
he was just trying to lessen the
punishment cuz then for him it was
saying like why would we say that we're
not guilty and then he's found or that
he's not guilty and then he's found
guilty and then at that point asked the
the jury for leniency in the sentences
because the jury the jury is the same
one that would somehow determine the
sentencing as well so that's what the
lawyer was saying like I was just trying
to back you up and make sure you don't
get sent to death row so that were
there's so much evidence that the lawyer
was like oh he's for sure gonna get
convicted as guilty so we might as well
jeez yeah but the the court still
charged McCoy anyway and then they still
charge McCoy chews on his tongue and
pretend it's gum all apparently I think
he hung back-to-back I actually have gum
look why did you eat you're not supposed
to chewing come on you're not a chew gum
on this show I got in trouble you get
pointing away yeah nobody said that
so then McCoy did not agree with what
the lawyer was proposing and so he tried
to fire English but the judge said that
it was already too late and so in 2011
McCoy was convicted of first-degree
murder and sentenced to death
and so in 2017 McCoy argued that his
constitutional rights as a criminal
defendant were violated he said quote
Your Honor this is unconstitutional for
you to keep an attorney on my case when
this attorney is completely selling me
out also the sixth amendment guarantees
a right to the assistance of counsel
and so other lawyers that are commenting
on this they're saying that English's
actions were wrong because again McCoy
did not agree if he did agree then I
would have been perfectly fine and so
the lawyer should have been fighting for
what the client wants because at the end
of it all it's a client that ends up
suffering the consequences now where
we're at is they're they're trying to
McCoy is trying to see if this can all
be appealed somehow it with the Supreme
Court pretty sentence to death right
down yeah that's why I went all the way
to Supreme Court granted usually on
death row you got like 12 years unless
you're in Texas sir right and they're
just gonna totally dismiss his point
that they were a part of a drug
conspiracy with yeah that was so
breathed over in the article like I want
to know more about that team - yeah how
did he come to that conclusion I watched
plenty of movies where the police is
also involved in a drug smuggling yeah I
just want to see it I believe that I
mean it happened so much than it's a
movie troll 'inna monster we just watch
the dr. Mayer documentary about Eileen
from you know there was one I forget her
last name like come on I'm Wuornos homie
well there you go Jake oh yeah so the
lady who the movie monster was based off
of and she is like the police wanted me
to kill because like they they want him
to make a movie out of this and because
she was the first female serial killer
and she was like they knew I was like
you know she said they knew I was
killing and they let me keep killing
because they wanted me to be a serial /
oh yeah that's what she says that's what
the news - yeah yeah so what was her
thing like how does she know they were
letting her do it
well she that's what she thinks cuz she
was leaving evidence [ __ ] everywhere
she's like I didn't do a glove like my
head my fingerprints were all over the
place like like I was just killing these
guys and warming the dishes and stuff
she wasn't like trying to cover her
tracks
yeah it was too easy for her right she's
like you guys are that 13 like it was it
was like 13 but it started off in
self-defense so like she had killed like
seven guys that look try to rape her
like
I'll abused her and she was a pop
prostitute you guys would get weird but
then most but then towards the end she
just started killing for money like so
like at first cuz she was getting away
with it so it was like well now and then
that's when her values started getting
getting shifted cuz it was like money
that was an easy way to get money and
yeah but then in the court
they didn't even they didn't believe her
that it was self-defense at all in any
other cases and then they were letting
her sit on death row forever and she's
just like kill me already just kill me
but they wouldn't let her get killed
either
and then charlize theron when I won an
award because she made herself looking
ugly for the purse don't you love that
[ __ ] when they do that
like when Nicole Kidman had a fake nose
on for the hours to make herself look
uglier they are like you're so brave
that's [ __ ] crazy but surely Stan was
really good acting like she was [ __ ]
bomb now are the justice system is so
[ __ ] up yeah the people in it don't
even believe in it anymore
yeah there's no it's just a big game no
it's just like no lawyers they're always
like broken I was sued before and that's
when I realized yes that system was
[ __ ] because if you have more money
you win that's exactly how it works like
if you have more money you are the
winner that's what happened out all
through the 90s with Microsoft did like
Microsoft would just like basically
wholesale take companies yeah that's why
they get ideas they would do their [ __ ]
for free and they'd [ __ ] this whole
company over and then if this company
tried to assume they just [ __ ] sued
back and just like sued them out of
existence that's why Microsoft had so
many virus problems cuz then those
companies would become virus makers and
they would only know
yeah PCs and stuff and now everyone's
like Bill Gates is the [ __ ] man cuz
he he went on reddit and he gave he
would did reddit Secret Santa and gave
away X boxes and [ __ ] like it I love it
I love it well the kids on reddit don't
even remember the 90s so I mean they
don't they weren't alive so doesn't
matter this is McCoy Hatfield and McCoy
and this is English English doesn't
practice law anymore he's in real estate
development that looks like a real
estate better record yeah no not a not a
lawyer particular people's lives yeah